inoculate yourself with positive word to
make yourself unstoppable yeah out of
your mind the polluting negative
thoughts that's causing most people to
go through life being stuck because they
are volunteer victims many people died
aged 25 and don't get buried until
they're 65 because they got so much
garbage in their minds you are here
because you've got a clear vision of
what you want and where you're going you
want more you're different than
everybody else don't worry if they don't
get it don't try and convince people a
person convinced against their will is
of the same opinion still you are not
like everybody else you can walk outside
and find pigeons but if you're looking
for Eagles it's gonna take you a minute
you are different it's lonely at the top
it's lonely at the top but you eat
better it's hard changing your life it
was hard when Jeff's over three years
ago in the Penobscot building in Detroit
Michigan where I was operating my
business and I fell on some hard times
and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope and I opened the
envelope and the envelope was from
management that said this is an office
tower it's not a hotel please do not
sleep in your office and I said excuse
me sir I said I just worked long hours
in creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor look at her
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life
don't stop don't stop don't stop running
toward your dream for those of you that
have experienced some hardships don't
give up on your dream don't stop running
toward your dream you just watched two
amazing clips from Les Brown take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life
belief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]